howdy y'all I'm Evy ugly and I'm here at
BuzzFeed to answer 30 questions in three
minutes in a suitcase on the floor at
the hotel room I think it might have
been Sam Smith's how do you sleep you
gotta like start your day fresh so you
have to like cleanse me I'm a drag queen
I love me it's me what's the shower
Brianna she's just the baddest she's so
dope she can do anything she could pull
up any hair
I'd say kooky chill and then angry I'm
an angry person blow someone or write
ask ela you're automatically hide just
by being there you wake up and you're
higher than everybody you don't feel any
pain drag it's just fun and easy it has
to be the jellyfish I knew that was
gonna be iconic long before that ever
got on drag race I was like ooh this is
gonna be the stuff that gets me on drag
race and then makes me win it look how
it happened I really liked Amsterdam a
la everyone was super chill they were
chill Cheetos I love Hot Cheetos or just
hot sauce in general actually a hot
sauce straight-up I would actually
really love to do something with Alaska
cuz she's good at music and she makes a
joke out of her music that's just
everything probably that little like
mischievous type all the one that's like
you know I knew it would have happened
I'm fine with it I wish people would
just stop adding me though
it's creepy yeah they were willing to
lie to me about being a fan first I just
do I just fall into it it's probably
banana because I'm allergic to them in
real life
so like fake banana flavor is this you
know there's drama everywhere to nanmura
to work the world docu-series to find
out I wasn't good at anything else
that's why I became a drag queen
I'd need music
like munchies probably pot to go along
with those munchies I'm sorry
hey there I'm sorry oh god I would never
be a dog sleep or if it's not sleep then
stare grumpily at whoever's keeping me
from sleeping right now I'm really
really into like some old-school Grace
Jones make sure you check out vas events
com2 grab your tickets to work the world
tour starting basically right now come
see me in a city near you
[Laughter]
adios I've got more cooking to do
[Music]